Speaker 1: Let's go to Christian
from California. Christian, welcome.
Christian from California. Welcome.
Speaker 2:
Can you hear me okay?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: So I'm actually calling you from
the campus of my high school right now. And
I'm just wondering, what exactly do you think
is, you know, how Biden just forgave some
student loan debt? What do you see as like
the long term solution to like how college
is becoming more and more unaffordable?
Speaker 1: The long term solution is it's
not going to be just forgiving some debt. The long
term solution is going to be something has to put
some combination of downward pressure on the
educational costs and upward pressure on wages
so that they are in line in a way that makes a lot
more sense. And unfortunately, I don't really see
a clear path to that right now. I do think free
community college for two years for an associate's
degree would do some of it. So if people had the
option of paying for four years at an expensive
school or doing your first two years for free at
community college and then only doing two years at
the expense of four year school, your junior and
senior year to finish out your four year degree.
I think that that would put significant
downward pressure on what the four year
schools are able to charge, for example. I know
this one isn't popular with a lot of people, but
if it were a little more difficult to just get
a student loan to cover your entire education,
now, by more difficult, I mean, maybe it
has to be tied to something that makes
it more in line with the expected wages
for that degree or so. I don't know. It's
difficult that might put downward pressure on
education costs, but it's very difficult. But I
don't believe the solution is for giving a little
bit of debt here and there or even forgiving all
of it, because those are basically licenses for
colleges to charge whatever the hell they want.
Speaker 2: What was it always sort of this
easy? I mean, like I don't know how long
federal student loans have been around, but how
have they always been so accessible to just about
anyone who wants it? I mean, sign up for one.
Speaker 1: No, but they also weren't as in demand,
because there was a time during which you could
kind of like work your way through college.
The idea of that is kind of
absurd at this point in time.
So they've become more accessible as they've
become more in demand. So it's been both.
Speaker 2: Right. I have a patient at a clinic
I work at who says she went to Berkeley in the
sixties and was able to pay for it working
part time, which is insane to think of now.
Speaker 1: Thom Hartmann, who's a talk radio host
on the left, he talks about how his wife, Louise,
I believe it's that she was able to basically
waitress through college and pay for it and
come out with I think it's almost no debt.
Speaker 2: Wow. That's that's crazy to think
about. All right, David, thank you so
much for your time and taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you so much for the
question. Yeah, it's a lesson that the student
loan debt forgiveness alone is not the solution
to the problem. That's that's for damn sure